caging skies the book that this film is
based on there we go
has something in common with your film
but a lot of things not in common with
your film I'm curious about when you
read this and what you seized upon it
what you seized upon it that made you
want to tell this story yeah so my 2010
my mother was reading this book not that
coffee and her own coffee I've got many
great stories like this and she said
this story is so boring she said you
should make this into a movie and she
described the story to me and but the
way she described it was sort of she
sort of said the it's about this boy in
the Hitler Youth whose mother's hiding
his girl in in their attic and and she
sort of made it sound a little bit like
lit the right one in like words like
that he thought that there was a monster
in his attic instead so and I read the
book in the book is it's a really good
book but it's not really how she
described it and it's a lot darker it's
a very bad book and so I but I did love
the idea of this this kid who I like the
challenge of styling a film with a kid
who sort of want to hate really just
because of who he is and how he's been
you know in doctrines into this thing
and his attitudes and I like the idea of
that being sort of torn away and and him
changing they're making a really big
change by the end and so I took the the
sort of the bones of that story the you
know the hem and Alice's relationship
and you know I wrote their into a script
and then added Hitler and jokes and were
you the first choice to play Hitler I
mean obviously look at me
[Laughter]
when that casting thing comes up to play
an Aryan in Nazi Germany first person
you think of to the Polynesian Jew so no
wasn't i right so I wrote it and okay
ended it was like 2011 I finished the
script had no intention of playing their
character and we sort of sent the script
out and just agents to see who might be
interested in this thing and but at that
very time at every moment we Jemaine and
I got financing to make what we're doing
the shadows and so I went back New
Zealand and made that then got
distracted again and made hunt for the
world of people think got distracted
again and made four and then after three
films remembered I haven't done that yet
and then decide to make it mess with Fox
Searchlight read it and they loved it
and they said we want to make it but we
only want to make it if you play Hitler
so it's their fault but the upside of
you're waiting those years is Roman
would have been about when you're old
and not really ready to play Jojo so
it's good would have been harder Roman
do you remember your first meeting with
Tycho or how you found out about this
this film a direction I just had so much
good luck that he'd and then I'll be
great he just completely free Jeffries I
just saw I have to do this all the time
now
no I didn't get the part I thought but
I'm going home just sleeping for now I
just felt so bad as like oh god the guy
probably thinks I'm just really
narcissistic ten-year-old they won't do
anything he's told but no he didn't
really I just think that but that's what
I wanted what did you see in Roman that
made him right for the part I'm gonna
give you a compliment now I don't
usually do this
the room was very sensitive and
emotionally mature emotionally connected
and so the thing about Rome and this is
true he cares deeply about people and
whenever I'm casting children I try and
find I try and find kids that are as
close as possible to the character of
written and and that's really like most
of the work is done then they just need
to learn their lines and then say them
asked so yes so it was a big sense of
relief to find him and then also
Thomason as well who auditioned very
early on and was basically basically was
the front-runner from that moment on
Thomason
there are ways that we've seen this
character in the past and it's often a
survivor slash victim and yet I think
the way you play Elsa she is like the
coolest girl who is in an unfortunate
horrible circumstance but she is really
in control of what's gonna happen to
where she is a powerful person and not
somebody who has been victimized yeah I
think that was something that was really
important to take and I was too yes
obviously
Elster as a victim and has is going
through a really really monstrous time
and history she is also that's the fact
that she is a victim isn't what defines
her she is really she's strong and
courageous and and smart and kind and
caring and there's so many other things
and has so many layers just like onions
and trick and she yeah she's a cool kid
and man I think I can I wanted to show
that so yeah yeah Sam when you were
thinking about research are there films
he could draw upon for gay Nazis what is
the what is the what is the can in there
no not really I couldn't but I did watch
the young
and I watched ray Fiennes and
Schindler's as I watched Oscar Verne and
ship of fools but we talked about Bill
Murray actually like stripes Bill Murray
yeah and sort of a if Bill Murray was at
a German accent he was a disillusion
Nazi that was sort of the yeah that was
my Mean Girls
yeah stripes and meatballs yeah Sam
Aiona asked about how Tyco works and
what he gives actors how much you are
able to depart how much you're able to
improvise what are the rules on set and
how do you make sure you're getting the
tone right I think we just wanted to
play it real I think Tyco is just really
charismatic and charming as you can see
and he it's just a very freeing
environment you know you you have you
have a lot of fun and but there wasn't
as much ad libbing I mean I think I feel
like you and Steven ëthe lived more
maybe yeah I mean this group was such a
good template and the characters
obviously probably Steve and I were the
strong Nazi stereotypes and so we kind
of got that brief and went with it and -
I could like you liked a lot of options
as well so yeah it was it was hard to to
improvise a look at this stuff it's
uncomfortable one time I think you made
me do a run for like 10 minutes about
Jewish noses and and then the head of
Fox was kept watching incredibly big
nose and I knew he was in the room at
the end of the ten-minute run and Tiger
kept on encouraging me like this I was
saying you should start by called it
really wasn't he really wasn't and I
haven't worked for Fox since you won't
and you won't ever again
but my friends at Fox
but rebel I think it's also important
what's happening in the world at this
time in the war and that is that
obviously war is going badly and
characters like you are see an
opportunity that women are going to be
on the front lines along with young
children very soon and even though trial
line robbed by the by the end the women
we're really holding the machine guns
and yeah so I liked that that was that's
kind of reference in the film there's a
lot of stuff that I think wouldn't if
you were if you're watching this you
might think that's a bit over the top
but most of the stuff in the film around
the city and everything I researched in
its based on factual stuff like all the
kids dressed as robots and toothpaste
tubes just photos of that that's what
they made them do walk around getting
metal so they could make more bombs and
a lot of my dialogue was taken from real
teaching books so it sounds a bit like
jokes but they were actually real
sentences I'm wondering if that is
actually something that's mirrored in
your own life that you meet people who
may not be knowledgeable about what
happened during the war and about death
camps and about at the Holocaust a lot
of people will have been unsure about
this film because of the fact that it's
a comedy about world war two and they're
scared that it maybe it's too early or
not appropriate and I think it's
important that it's a comedy and it's
important that we're looking at it
through a young person person's eyes
because that makes it much more
accessible to the younger generations
and then and theirs into a movie where
you feel like you're being taught to
listen it's a movie where you feel like
you're being included in the
conversation I guess yeah Stephen
Merchant who isn't here
he he he told a story which I'm sure
most of you know about Groucho Marx and
I think it was probably butchering the
story but I'm about his daughter orcas
and way back series it wasn't allowed to
swim in in a pool in Beverly Hills
because she was Jewish and rather than
rather than then respond with vitriol
and an attack
of this place he you know in typical
Groucho way and this was like the point
is that comedy is a very very important
and and and strong weapon against ideals
and doctrines and things that they're
that they're really are based in sort of
absurdity and he replied back with a
letter that said well to be fair she's
half Jewish so would you consider
letting her into the pool up to her
waist and if you can respond you know in
a very intelligent way and poke fun and
pull the thread you know a way that is
sort of holding up this sort of flimsy
belief then it's a other things a much
more powerful way and a much more
effective way of attacking there I'm
wondering how you saw this parent
missing parent missing mother story
fitting into what you've done before and
why that's an important thing for you to
explore as a filmmaker
well my films are usually yeah they
usually about children and their parents
or father figures with mother figures
this previously I guess they've been
more father centric and this one is
really a love letter to to mothers in
particular my mother and also solely
mothers some solo parents I guess who
was until I became a parent that I
realized the sacrifices that parents go
through and just how hard it is to raise
a kid and so but you know it coupled
with being a parent in a time like this
where you know you're losing your child
to the other side to indoctrination and
being brainwashed by the bad guys and
you know for in the healthy youth when
these kids win and one of the first
things they were taught was to rebel
against your parents don't listen to
your parents just listen to us and if
they say anything about us or anything
that's negative towards the party tell
us and we'll deal with them and so if
she knew that and every parent knew that
it's a very tough situation to be and
you can't just you know come out and say
you shouldn't be a naughty it's like you
know it's it's it's not as simple as
that for her and Scarlett I think it's
such a brilliant job and I think she's
just incredible in this film and a lot
of that character
when I was riding I was inspired by
Ellen Burstyn and Alice doesn't live
here anymore cuz think it's one of the
great solar mother characters and and
yeah I think it's she's really the only
sane person in the film and I think
that's like in her Ian Thomas and the
basic that not uribl that the these two
women those super men are like the ones
that you really like rooting for and you
want you know and they it seem to be the
only grounded characters good
you shot interiors for this film it
burned off studios burned off studios
during the war was taken over by a
company called prog film that was run by
Joseph Goebbels and they made 82 films
during the war that burned off that were
propaganda films obviously alright don't
want I don't I do not support Baron buff
studios okay they're terrible terrible
stupid
a lot of good films have come out of
Baron dogs since then but it made me
think about the power of film and what
movies can be used for for better and
for worse and I guess we ever aware of
that history while you were filming and
does it start to make you think about
how this film especially for a younger
generation can fill a void that seems to
need filling yeah that I was aware of
the the history of Behrend off and and
it was extremely weird walking around
the corridors and not just without films
but seeing other acts as an extra
walking around with you know this German
uniforms on I mean they make so many
World War two films they're even that's
weird and just knowing I guess the other
history and like this you know that's
it's not a ghost but there's like it's
sort of you know there's the residue in
those studios that was very aware of and
and it's a in a similar way when I first
put on that that Hitler cost him in that
mustache which he ruined favor on that
massage and the haircut isn't start and
I looked in the mirror and usually if
I'm playing something you know you know
I'm embracing that character and this
time is just I was basically just
embarrassed to look in the mirror and
it's very felt like this is the sort of
weight on my shoulders and I think I've
probably spent much of the shoot rights
of
slumped over like this is just sad that
I had to look like that but then it's
also very hard to direct them and and
then realize what they're looking at you
the strange way and then you catch you a
reflection of yourself in something and
you're like God that's right
so anyway could you try and do it like
this
next time that's not look you don't have
to that's not in order you know you used
to but I had to try and like own it
and own that character and I could
convince myself that repurposing those
clothes or repurposing that look and
also repurposing Behrend off studios to
make films for good in films that are
full of hope and trying to make a
difference would change someone's
attitude is really the there's there was
like the kind of positive take and that
bolstered me a lot in going forward and
it's sort of yeah somehow previously
enjoyed
possessing Hill and India in like in
making him do whatever I wanted which
was just making him a complete idiot
thanks for coming out thank you for
[Applause]